[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host and of course an analyst on
football night in america chris joins us
on the program if tom brady was still
the quarterback of the patriots what
kind of offensive game plan would the
patriots have had last night
oh um i don't think it would have been
well but a little bit different i don't
think they're gonna throw the ball three
times i think they're gonna throw the
ball more than that you know first off
of course he's you know played more
football you can trust them in the
situation a little bit more and you know
listen one of the things that's amazing
about the game is we know the elements
were bad and one team won with three
throws to me the other amazing thing
about the game was
a quarterback in josh allen where they
just said well throw it 30 times who
cares if hurricane wins you could throw
it through it and he did i mean that's
the amazing thing and i think brady
would be somewhere along those lines not
that new england would have to rely on
the past the way the bills do
but i think brady's arm you know how big
his hands are his arm is one of the more
underrated things i think in the history
of the nfl where sometimes yeah i think
he's a little overrated in his goatness
i don't think he gets enough credit for
how powerful his arm is and how many
great games he had in tough with her
weather up in new england so let's say
he gets 15 to 20 throws last night
instead of just three if he's in new
england when is the game plan
finalized when you know with the weather
condition when do you think belichick or
josh mcdaniels went okay this is what
our philosophy is tonight i i think that
they probably started to really take
into account you know wednesday or
thursday at some point to realize hey
let's let's have a few extra runs in the
game plan
let's start to formulate a little bit of
the weather so bad that they had at
least a
uh uh a
de facto plan early in the week to go we
got to think about the game might be you
know not manageable through the pass
game so we got to think about ways to do
that and they're like again having
worked there i mean there's just no
stone unturned it just it's at any point
the details the smallest details the
most basic details they're they're just
constantly stressed day after day after
day and i would think early in the week
they were on this that it would be a
factor that they had to have at least
some sort of a plan to attack that i
know we want to give bill belichick
credit and he deserves a lot of credit
as maybe the greatest coach in nfl
history but right what role does josh
mcdaniel's offensive coordinator play in
saying this is what
i would like us to if belichick deals
with the defense and let josh deal with
the offense should we be crediting josh
mcdaniels not bill belichick well we
should give josh a lot of credit there's
no doubt but i think ultimately it still
goes back to bill belichick that's why
belichick's the greatest coach ever not
only is it about yes the defense and we
know all that but you know these long
staff meetings he has you know every day
after practice where it's it's coached
the coaches all of them doesn't matter
what side of the ball it is it's coach
the coach's time we're gonna go over it
and now i'm going to coach you on how to
coach each one of these positions and
what we should do in each situation and
you know and again even in my time there
dan mcdaniel's as smart as anybody i've
been around you know just
a tuesday
you know i could be there running around
making copies for things belichick and
mcdaniels could be in the corner of the
hallway talking i'd come back an hour
later they're still in the corner of the
hallway talking so i don't think
anything happens there without belichick
and even with the great offense of
mcdaniels and everything it's built
through bill belichick to your point of
why he's so great you know everything
they do on offense a lot of it is
wait when teams get in this formation
and i'm in this defense i don't like to
see this and then it's like mcdaniel's
going okay wait belichick doesn't like
to see this let me draw up the play to
do that then and that's how really the
offense has been formulated there in new
england to even accentuate you know uh
belichick's greatness what would we be
saying if the
patriots had the philosophy of three
passes and they lost last night
uh we would have been going i mean
three passes i mean i understand being i
mean they didn't blow them out chris
i know i know i think we'd all be going
i mean at least let's get to eight or
ten like i mean i think and and i i mean
i i think to what you're asking i listen
there was a point in the second half
where i was going i mean come on come on
can we just give one play action or one
boot here just to keep them a little
honest but he didn't want to take the
chance he didn't want to take the chance
out of them being in second and seven
and then third and four and their
ability to maybe even run the ball of
course they ran in a ton on third down
uh but yeah i think we would probably be
you know dissecting him a little bit in
the fact that we'd like to see a few
more passes more likely to miss the
playoffs the bills or the browns
oh i'm gonna still go with the browns on
that one you know i'm hopeful for the
browns because there's so much talent on
the team
but
i'm hopeful only because of that like
the defense is all over the place you've
heard me say dan before you know when
the run game isn't good the pass game in
cleveland just not good enough to stand
alone so that's an issue for me buffalo
you know again it's still josh allen
he's a superstar definitely one of the
best quarterbacks in the football that
defense is still very good uh i i still
have more faith in them close one last
night
josh allen's wearing longer spikes
against the tennessee titans they
probably win that game when they're down
there running the quarterback sneak and
he slips late in the fourth quarter you
know i i think it's been more consistent
in buffalo throughout the year than
cleveland that's for sure and buffalo's
been losing to all the teams that
they're gonna have to compete with if
they get to the playoffs like they they
don't have like what's the signature win
here and i i i just don't get a good
feeling i didn't have a good feeling to
start the year and thought they relied
on josh allen too much right that's
right um but i no and and i wonder if
cleveland would have been better if they
had gone to case keenum
and instead of letting baker mayfield go
out there uh injured
yeah i i get that you know i you know
hey baker does bring value there's no
doubt and that's where the coaches got
to figure out like at what point is he
hurting the offense
you know so that's a real thing and it's
again the games haven't been good but i
also could sit there dan and you know
look at it and go yeah baker the detroit
lion game for sure missing throws on
that one but some of these other games
as a late too i want to just i watch
some plays and go where do you want them
to throw the ball yeah where the new
england game i mean there's nobody open
baltimore game i didn't come away
watching that film going oh man people
are open baker really messed up not at
all and that's where they're a little
underwhelming and your point about i
think buffalo is spot on too you know if
you're not if you're staying the same
you're getting worse it's like they kind
of just went wait we were good last year
we'll do it all again this year no you
need to improve your football team a
little bit and it is too josh allen
reliant uh to your point and i think the
other thing too is what we've seen like
especially in the tennessee the colts
and the patriots losses when there's an
overpowering big offensive line running
football team they're a little
compromised they're not a big front
seven team they want to play basically
nickel all game long and you know again
if they can get you to over play the run
the way they did in all those games if
you can just pass a little you can
expose them and of course last night
they didn't even have to pass to still
have their way he's chris sims pro
football talk live co-host the show that
precedes ours on peacock with mike
florio if i said you can have the chiefs
of the patriots the rest of the year
chiefs i mean no sorry patriots patriots
oh yeah i'm sorry i'm not taking the
chiefs yet i can't do that yet no you
know again i like what the chiefs
defense is doing you know i know the
patriots is not sexy but
neither was 2001 super bowl run i mean
just get used to 20 to 17 23 to 14. i
just think that's the style of play they
are but they're too consistent on both
sides of the ball you know again the
other night with the chiefs offense they
just can't
seem to be consistent or get out of
their own way whether it's drop passes
mahomes still missing throws where i'd
go man
the average nfl quarterback should make
that throw let alone patrick mahomes all
these years i see him do it with his
eyes closed you know so it's just a it's
a crazy year from that standpoint of i
haven't seen a guy that was so amazing
you know kind of come back to earth and
just not be that amazing in a lot of
moments during during the year we're
running out of mvp candidates
feels like it's tom brady
then there's a big separation
i guess aaron rodgers i guess mahomes is
in there i can't put josh allen in there
no you can't i don't think you can put
my homes in there either way you know
you can't i don't think you can we all
want to
the touchdowns are going to be there
jonathan miller
right i mean hey that's one guy i'll
look at for sure i think that could be
in this conversation maybe if tj watt
gets on fire here the last few weeks and
gets the 22 sacks somewhere in that
range but again i don't know
they give it to the defensive player of
the year i mean that's i know how they i
know they separate that but it feels
like
brady is just being brady maybe nothing
special but that might be good enough
because everybody else has been
inconsistent
no doubt i think you know really kyla
murray being out for a month is it's
going to cost him the mvp because i
think there's a good chance they do end
up with the top seed in the nfc playoffs
and he'd be that guy like they jumped on
the scene this year he's the quarterback
we know how dangerous he was so his
injury affected that i would i'm with
you in the fact that yeah it's probably
brady from the facts of
wins and stats
you know but
i guess what i would say a little bit is
the name you brought up to me aaron
rodgers right now
again as annoying as he was during the
cover thing he you know is
just a poster child for mvp we see how
average they are without him when he
wasn't in there you know he's special
again i don't think any of us think that
the supporting cast is that great it's
good no doubt but not great
you know and and to me he is just a big
what he does to the line of scrimmage
having a feel for the overall game you
know i i would look at him and brady and
probably jonathan taylor's the three
guys no i think it's going to hurt
rogers with what happened uh yeah
you're right yeah yeah and it should
because you know you're going to be the
most valuable player but then you miss
the kansas city game and maybe cost your
team the number one seed yes right i
agree that's going to come back to bite
him in the butt most likely but yeah the
way the brady is throwing the ball their
offense just continues to attack it
seems like you're going again they're
going to get the wins and he's going to
have the numbers to match it it seems
like it's lining up for that what's your
opinion on the uh pseudo slide by kenny
pickett the pittsburgh quarterback in
the acc title game oh
oh
it makes me want to puke
i'm i'm sick of it i'm sick of all this
protecting the quarterback crap i mean
that's like cheating right there it's
cheating
it really is i you know again i'm not
mad at him he's don't hate the player
hate the game i understand that but to
me this is again this is another just
little snippet of information that we
have the protecting the quarterback has
gone
we were just overboard overboard the
some of the horrible calls in the nfl
the horrible call last night josh allen
is running he jumps in bounds and gets
hit and they call
hitting the quarterback too hard again
uh i i didn't like it i really don't and
uh i think that football has got to do
something about it wait do you think
quarterbacks are embarrassed by the
protection they receive
like i think they know how embarrassing
it is but they're going to try to do all
they can to take advantage of it i think
they know i mean you know i think brady
and rogers and josh allen like they're
tough football-minded guys not just
quarterbacks but i think they also
they they realize yeah i mean this bad
footballs getting rewarded hey we didn't
protect nobody was open but you hit me
too hard it's great first down fantasy
owners we're still going offense is good
i think they knows how embarrassing it
is but they're going to do their best to
get a free 15 all they can and i can't
be mad at them for that brady would not
still be playing if this was the 1970s
no way or the 80s
again yeah right he would not you know i
i i i would have a hard time thinking so
i mean just watching you know my dad dan
marino john elway
uh troy aikman i mean the beating they
took i mean you know the dead weight
rule i mean reggie white literally used
to pick my dad up and just drop his
weight on him and body slam him and you
know my dad's shoulders are still paying
the price for that i mean he would have
a little more cartilage might be able to
throw the ball overhand to his grandkids
but he can't do that oh wow yeah yeah
that's an issue there yeah yeah yeah
just
does tampa have any issues that concern
you heading into the home stretch
a little bit
a little they do you know that hasn't
been clean the last two weeks i mean
they were begging for the colts to beat
them the colts out played them you know
again last week atlanta hung around
had some long drives defensively not
playing that good right now it's one of
the first films i'm gonna go watch here
dan when i get done just because hey
matt ryan and company had a little
success running the football but man you
know they're letting up a lot of plays
in the pass game they are and i know
they're just getting healthy in the
secondary but you know not playing at
the elite level that i think they're
capable of that's for sure you know
they're winning games i know that but i
don't think it's their best football
great to talk to you buddy thank you
chris
thanks man be good that's chris sims pro
football talk live co-host and
contributor to football night in america